ahmed devrait être à l'école à cette
heure ci mais pour lui la fin des
classes a sonné il ya plus de trois ans
avec le son des explosions et des tirs
dans la banlieue de damas où il vivait
avec sa famille
sow avait imaginé avoir arrêté votre
travail que tout le cours de la vie
s'arrête pour vous et votre famille dit
son père
comment est ce qu'un être humain puisse
se sentir comment croyez vous que
quelqu'un dont la vie s'est arrêtée il
ya 4 5 ans ce sens les autobus bjork et
j'admire ahmad mohamad n'aime pas
repenser à ce moment où sans comprendre
ce que cela signifiait vraiment ils ont
tout laissé derrière forcé à l'exil que
les farc au repos j'ai tout perdu dans
mon pays dit-il
mes ambitions mes accomplissements bas
mais je sens qu au canada
je pourrais accomplir des choses éduquer
mes enfants et que ma femme et moi
pourrons utiliser nos compétences et
c'est ce qu'il espère faire très bientôt
mohammad un avocat sa femme et leurs
trois enfants ont été acceptées par le
canada comme réfugiés ils n'attendent
plus que le signal de départ quand on
l'a dit j'ai senti que ma visite arrêté
reprenait en quittant l'ambassade
j'ai retrouvé l'espoir mohammad c'est
que depuis les attentats de paris
de nombreuses voix s'élèvent au canada
et ailleurs pour affirmer leur
inquiétude de voir autant de réfugiés
arrivés si vite mais pour le syrien
d'abord interrogé par le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés des nations
unies et ensuite révéré au canada le
processus de sélection a semblé très
long trop long et l'admr et non non ça
nous a surpris dit mohammad
nous avons fait une entrevue puis une
autre et une autre ensuite des examens
médicaux du nhs se sent un peu comme
dans un labyrinthe perdu en attendant de
savoir si on va partir ou pas enfin avec
plus d'un million deux cent mille
réfugiés enregistrés ici et des dizaines
et des dizaines de milliers
ne sont pas le liban considère avoir
fait le plein il ne permet plus
l'enregistrement de nouveaux réfugiés
par le haut commissariat des nations
unies à d'autres de faire leur part pour
le liban la perspective de dpi resserre
les critères d'admissibilité ou
ralentissent l'accueil des réfugiés
syriens et une bien mauvaise nouvelle
les réfugiés syriens sont partout au
liban et vivent dans des conditions
souvent difficiles les camps ne sont pas
permis par les autorités libanaises
ce qui n'empêche pas les campements
informels de tapisser le paysage ici les
parents ont obtenu la permission d'un
cultivateur de planter leurs tentes à
même les champs de pommes de terre
en échange de leur travail eux ne sont
pas rémunérés
alors les enfants aussi sont mises à
contribution contre environ 5 dollars
par jour
pour ahmad lui arrive à payer les 250
dollars de loyer mensuel pour cet
appartement à quelques kilomètres des
champs ces enfants n'ont pas à
travailler mais c'est pour eux qu'il
rêve du canada même s'ils habitent ils
les rigueurs de l'hiver l'inquiète c'est
assez de temps perdu dit-il
l'avenir de mes enfants est en train de
s'évaporer et il est convaincu que sa
famille arrivera à s'intégrer à sa
nouvelle terre d'accueil
c'est une société multiculturelle dit il
et multiethnique avec tout leur religion
et leur race
si on n'embrasse pas cette idée on
retourne au moyen âge
mohammad a vu plus regardé en arrière
nous sommes ici marie-eve bédard radio
canada majdel anjar ou liban